hello reject nation mofos are here
Greg jte movie thinks you've seen him on
screen junkies you've seen him dominate
the Schmo down and now he is here
upgrading for all of that welcome back
after five seconds of filming different
time span for you guys the reject nation
hey JT I know that you did a reaction to
the first venom trailer we did not do
reaction to the second trailer seen it
though right I did a lot of people are
talking about it because we got the one
thing I think everybody wanted from the
first trailer well there's a guy named
aldo jones good friend of the channel
okay and familiar well he has some great
videos you should check it out this is
new for him what do you do as a 4k 60
frames per second video if you can
combine both trailers into one or
something like that that could be wrong
we're gonna watch this and then I would
love to hear your thoughts about venom
it's gonna be super clear I know that's
what it means don't don't talk down to
me my god for me and hence really wow
that is fancy
thank you for bringing this collectively
do this morning
it is a moment it's so mean you dream of
claiming history starts today is this
the I think this is the new one yeah
yeah it doesn't say one yeah because I
remember the Association was an evil
person I don't want my phone works Benny
are you gonna behave yourself tonight I
told you money do my job I'm a reporter
I follow people that do not want to be
followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people I know about
you when I think it's a party I think
reporter we call them symbiosis wow this
is great
Oh
I haven't seen this since I did my react
[Music]
I'm here
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people picking up more in his
performance now I'm actually yeah
I can rewatch on this end
because wonder things you homos dear
you should be
what the hell are you alright let's see
this woo
yeah
the symbiont stuff looks much better at
4k actually I would say I'd say that
stuff looks better 4k well I still think
there's more I think he combined them
how's their 4k more oh that's for they
have you Oh what is this
I think it's the very first trailer
which I haven't seen in months is a long
time or whatever I first dropped that
morning
[Music]
maybe it's a breakup are they broken up
maybe let's copy this fish on whatever
it is you used to be one thing you're
something else there are times I prefer
the 4k at times I know
we all have problems
Dinah's
[Music]
cool
[Music]
I dig the music I dig the music - good
job aldo jones i looked really good to
share your thoughts because you didn't
get a chance to share your thoughts
there's more time party being a reporter
in this one i just don't buy him as a
reporter too much I see him I think
there's a guy who might be a homeless
MMA fighter I don't think a guy who
worked for like the San Francisco
Cardinal or Boston Globe is it because
you have a hard time getting past Tom
Hardy yeah I really do he just looks
like he just had like a three day
drinking bender and he's just waking up
like he doesn't look like what I would
think a reporter would be like he's
doing interview like it seems like I'm
not miscast almost there's side law
party though don't get me wrong lol
Marty he looks like he's having fun with
playing Eddie Brock I said that the
first time I watch it like he's doing
like a nice guy Eddie thing re watching
it again wow he is like super nice his
inflection and everything is actually
gonna hurt the bad people but he seems
kind of cowardly where does this take
place
well San Francisco but I think Eddie
Brock in New York I grew up watching the
cartoon in the comics yeah how are they
gonna get around not having the spare me
a black suit because that's originally
where then I'm assumin ight attaches the
spider-man and uses like what you
learned being persuader yeah to create
venable I think they're gonna be in
reference to it somehow I don't know at
this point I'm like I'm gonna try to
move past it the second trailer he
played is actually the first show that
was really yes or if that narration is
actually in the movie is it the opening
I kind of like Ben Raimi spider-man
movies Who am I
you sure you want to know or is it just
trailer voiceover there's one scene
where like he does this Professor X
Tyler Jean Grey style everything just
kind of in the office yeah yeah like
what is that about
he doesn't have Jean Grey powers I think
Tom Hardy probably gave a charismatic
performance I think was a Riz Ahmed is
the bad guy is that what was from night
of and yeah one I thik him I like you
too I feel like he's gonna be a crappy
villain I just get the strong impression
he's gonna be a bad I know he looks like
just a corporate douchebag yeah it looks
like but it's like you didn't cast a
white guy so good on you guys
there been rumors that carnage might be
the villain maybe because if you give me
a trailer or carnage my interest level
goes up like a hundred percent actually
it's a little overblown especially with
no spider-man no bring it on
you'll get much darker than carnage yeah
dark he's supposed to be antihero
Venom's originally like a villain who
kind of becomes a good guy yeah yeah
yeah carnage is full-on bad guy he's a
psycho yeah yeah ginger he could like
make blades and stuff he's a serial
killer it would be cool to have that
yeah how do you make your bad guy look
like a hero you get a bigger bad guy
that's true or you get rosamma to fight
him it's a suit on him it becomes
carnage but a different version of yeah
that'd be cool I mean this is all a
different version of the cops anyway
guys gave us homecoming we need to make
more money
we need to spider-verse honestly this
feels a little bit more in town would
like the amazing spider-man totally yeah
than it does the other does it feel like
a Raimi's spider-man doesn't feel like
the MCU spider-man but somehow it feels
like the amazing spider-man world it
feels like they're continuing that
universe in some way who talks about
them those movies are forgotten between
homecoming and Raimi no one ever brings
them up unless they bring about how
badly they'll be appreciated thirty
years from that was you actually pretty
good yeah there's two great spider-man
and there's that one stuck in the middle
just failed attempt I wish we could get
a little bit more Michelle Williams suit
you can't just use it yeah she's playing
love interest
listen I get that paycheck yeah Mark
Wahlberg ain't sharing guys this is why
you should subscribe to the real rejects
and click that notification belt check
out Alba Jones's channel jte movie
thinks check out his channel one day
he'll invite me on until that day comes
just go check out his solo channel don't
shake your head subscribe on my channel
I'm projecting power and dominance hit
subscribe its subscribe jte movie thinks
it's the only reason I'm here do it
camera off